- So, is it true that you still send Oprah
two thank you letters like a year?
- I do, you know Oprah
and I met in the late 90s
when she was in trial and
I was on the trial team.
And then I started doing the show
and then started doing the show a lot.
And then we launched the show
and it really changed my life a lot.
I had a great life when I met her
and I've got a great life now,
but she changed a lot of things
and it's just been really
important to me every year
to stop, sit down and
write her a letter and say,
"Thank you for the impact
you've had on me and my family."
And I've done it every
year for 25 or 26 years.
And she told me something one time,
the first time I launched
a book on her show,
I sent her like a huge flower arrangement
and a thank you note stuff
and I think she'd been on the
air 17 years at that point.
And she called me and said,
"You know about all the things I've done
"all the books and stuff," she said,
"This is the first time
anybody's ever said thank you."
- What?
- First time anybody's
ever said thank you.
- Oh, wow.
- And I thought, wow,
that's hard to believe.
- [Kelly] That's depressing.
Yeah.
- And now I've had my show for 20 years,
I understand what she means.
- Oh, man.
- I understand what she means.
And so I don't know, I've got this value,
don't forget who brung you to the dance.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And I've never let her think
I forgot who brung me to the dance.
- [Kelly] Yeah, I love that.